foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
how do you think she found out about
your stuff
well now I know you don't know her
I've never titty [__] with those
beauties
[Laughter]
what are we talking about how Jimmy
Kimmel said I look like Pete Sampras but
with Down Syndrome
it's like all right now that's my new
thing and then Sam you look like me with
Down Syndrome where we I was hoping like
Michael Phelps with Down Syndrome but
I'll take I'll take Corolla with that
well I'm I'm saying it's not enough that
you look like somebody you need to look
like the Down Syndrome version it was
tough I just look like down syndrome
down
which is a real bummer and then Haley
Joe Osment looks like you with Down
Syndrome so
look like you're a Handler I'm like he's
very functional they're gonna I like
your chin straps oh I'm trying dude why
are you doing this
you believe the science yes yes
right now by the way I think people are
beautiful I fell out of a tree last week
I'm just climbing a tree just [__]
around and uh back and because it would
look you never see a tree and it's so
climbable yeah low Branch there's not
many climbable trees for me
during the pandemic we would have shows
at Helium yeah and Williams a comedy
club Philly they would let us let me
book the show bring our friends and then
hang out after it was the only place we
could like go to a bar so big J would
come down every week and we would
he would bring Molly right we would all
do Molly and then it was like me Norman
and big J in the green room and he was
like come on guys do it normally was
like I don't know
you're so afraid of it he was like
[Laughter]
oh no I took a bus ride home that night
that was the craziest thing I didn't
stay over I just I get it I get it
because we were surrounded by Jay's
minions yes so it was like all right
let's get the [__] out anytime I took
Molly at that show I would go sit in the
manager's office by myself right and
every time I took Molly out that show
was a hilarious statement yeah
yeah
that is a great show it was such a good
show one time I got [__] in my dick
that'll get you yeah yeah and that hurts
yeah that's like leprosy it was bad it
was a throbbing pain how much [__] you
need in your dick to go like the need to
go there very little teeny bit tiny
amount like a BB how much [__] was in
her [__]
who said it was a lady true you've never
had a tongue in your ass no what several
several have tried dude
a picture
stop finally when I find the right woman
deep I have when I find the woman I
don't respect at all
I'll let her do it
a decent a-hole you seem like you're
hairlessly I am hairless thank you I do
it you got the body of an Asian boy yeah
I guess it feels like it'd be very pink
yep nice
everything yeah I'm a pink man yeah
you're a ham wallet yeah
yeah I think he might like it are you
afraid do you feel bad for them yes I
see yeah yeah that's how I feel that's
how I feel too yeah it's not fair it's
not right looks like Ari's beard
yeah the hairs down there grow different
oh yeah they're a little harder a little
coarser yeah the Rogue they're angry
yeah you're hairless really
like you you are your pink and hair you
are pink and hairless you're like a big
young Mouse
sucks again roasted by so many handsome
guys
literally the three ugliest guys I've
ever seen
that can't be true have you looked in
the audience
what's up fellas now we got some space
some distance on January 6 we could talk
about it yes you know well there was
another one like two weeks ago whatever
Tennessee yeah yeah they stormed in
Tennessee oh yeah the trans trans people
stormed it Transit just copying white
nationalists yeah right school shootings
insurrections yeah for real dicks so the
trans the trans
I need a topic real quick you need a
topic yeah I don't know what was the
1920s like damn it dude
how's that model T dude I threw up a
picture of me in a in college and people
were like oh where'd you get that
Throwback Pepsi can
how are your slaves oh my God are you
really it's right by my house
it's Harrisburg it's 15 minutes they had
a nuclear thing there my parents had to
yeah they'd evacuate damn yeah is that
why you got all [__] up yeah
comedy nothing better than a new
yorker's [__] thighs
dressed like a priest
Tony looks like he runs a gay funeral
home I do
I actually do male corpses only
we couldn't shut the casket I like to
put them in the coffin upside down
um
the final respect
open casket open mind you know what I
mean this is gay funeral director jokes
people I wasn't prepared we didn't say
that body is stiff
hey guys the embalming fluid has come
[Music]
[Applause]
that's funny
if Alex's water breaks it's gonna be
[__] Monster Energy drink
[Music]
it's a white trash
her mom's right there Shane shut up
[Laughter]
look different
your baby should have to do a [__]
Alex it's so weird seeing you with a big
butt so weird
um
hey pedophiles who don't [__] kids but
want to those are the real heroes
yeah they've got the urge cheat of the
city
or the playground
you know we're talking about tipping you
ever go to a strip club that doesn't
like throw ones at the ladies no yeah
what do they do one that happened to me
once in South Carolina we were sitting
there throwing ones and they're like
don't be [__] disrespectful we're
like all right well we thought you were
strippers yeah
I was just in Canada what I was just in
Canada this weekend we went to a strip
club I don't even [__] have once I
can't deal with that I only go to the
strip clubs that do Apple pay that's all
they do just go right by the [__] just
double click there's a barcode yeah
there a little red scanner comes out of
the snatch
you get under it I remember like the
very first one was just a stepmom
getting in bed with her son on vacation
yeah she and she was like what are you
hard
yeah oh my God fine I'll help that's
that was the ultimate yeah that was the
first one that was where they peppered
in there I go further give me blood
related really oh let's go blood yeah I
don't know yeah bring it on I mean I
don't want to do it but I want to watch
it because I want the Real Taboo the
step is not taboo to me they're not even
related so you want you just want to see
like identical twins 60 90. oh you're
like yes please yes please it's complete
now we're talking that's the serpent
eating its tails like yeah yin and yang
and they're Asian
my lady likes insults in bed and I can't
I can't do it wow yeah she wants to be
just mocked and ridiculed and I feel too
bad have you ever Googled it like what
you could say no I mean show me a
picture I'll tell you what to say
that's the thing is he can't be real you
should [__] be like we're never
getting married
you think I'd marry you what's the thing
I just say you're a bad driver and [__]
yeah that's that's but that doesn't you
know
maybe like you're a dumb [__] kind of
that's yeah that stuff well then just
that's fine I feel weird saying it okay
well then not guilty I just feel stupid
because she asked me to and then I do it
so it feels forced and weird
I call her a [__] you stupid [__] yeah
yeah wait how you [__] your fiance
and it's like through teeth like yeah
cause I feel so stupid holy [__] yeah a
lot I'm trying to think of insults
breath smells that would work I'll be
honest man
it's a very intense thing to be very
high on mushrooms on the biggest one in
America then you just listen to the dumb
[__] conversation you're like what
yeah I was fighting through that thing
that crypto thing I almost took a nap
you know what I mean Jamie you go what
the heck what the Katie don't you sit
around sometimes yeah that's what I do
Jamie what do you want to talk about
dude nobody ever asked James yeah that's
true you don't want to know he's a quiet
little guy
he's not little dude Jamie's yes
oh I take it all back take me some
monster you got more guns
[Music]